[Music]
abran my name is Jesse and today I am
with testing out five famous celebrity
omelette recipes to see which one is
actually the best today I'm with testing
recipes from Emeril Lagasse Julia Child
Geoffrey Zakarian Monsanto Morimoto
LL Cool J I studied up on all their
techniques weight all the ingredients to
level the playing field and I got three
of my friends to taste them in a blind
taste test so which celebrity chef is
the best omelette
let's start the egg experiment Emeril
Lagasse starts by placing some eggs
heavy cream salt and white pepper in a
blender and then blitzes that up until
it's nice and frothy so about 60 seconds
then you put some melted butter and puts
the egg mixture in a heated skillet and
pushes it around with rubber spatula
kind of like you're making scrambled
eggs this is just to get it to cook
evenly all over then he takes a spatula
and kind of smooths out the top to make
sure it's an even depth throughout put
some shredded cheddar cheese on top and
fold it into a half moon shape transfer
that onto a plate and bam even more
cheese you see eggs and cheese all the
time it's like peanut butter and jelly I
definitely like the coloration of it
look how thick that is I'm gonna go
ahead and get into it
after some regular eggs cheese is nicely
melted the eggs are cooked great this is
a good omelet I don't know made that one
but tastes like I made it it's really
good Mike's gonna finish this huh up
next is legendary chef and Julia Child
she starts with two eggs some salt and
pepper and blends those together with
some chopsticks she adds a little bit of
water to and also says you can use a
whisk and goes back and forth so I did
too
then she heats some butter in a skillet
and then adds the egg mixer to that and
this is where it gets cool you just
swirl swirl swirl and it magically turns
into an omelette you barely have to
touch it you can kind of piece it
together with the chopsticks but that's
about it
then she rubs some butter on top garnish
it with parsley and Bon Appetit this
looks like a fancy omelet yeah that's
thick it's like softer I like to texture
a lot I do like it but this is just very
fresh and light and I'm gonna eat this
with my pinky out because that's what
this tastes like
tastes way better with your pinky out up
next is Geoffrey Zakarian he starts with
three eggs and adds an extra egg yolk to
them to give a nice rich quality then he
adds and dice frozen
butter to it and mix a vet in he adds
that to a pan slowly heats it up so the
butter melts throughout and gets nice
and creamy kind of like you're making
soft scrambled eggs and then lets it set
for a second he seasoned the top with
salt and pepper and puts shredded
Gruyere cheese and chopped fresh herbs
on top he rolls it up with a spatula
transfers it to a plate and then
garnishes it with extra chopped herbs
and even more cheese to make a look nice
and fancy this omelet right here looks
really freaking good all right I like
the artistry I like the yellows with
some points for greens I'm seeing cheese
but I think I can smell that it's
Parmesan cheese I don't know it's not
doing much for me the texture is okay
it's a little too solid this person
definitely has different taste buds I
wish it was like more scramble they're
like more creamy it's a little bit of an
herb overload if you're into like very
stinky kind of funky cheese's and you'll
be into this omelette I'm not into
stinky funky cheese's so I ain't into
this omelette I like the way it looks
but not the way it tastes boo boo iron
chef morimoto starts by adding sugar
light soy sauce and dashi in a bowl and
stirring it together to dissolve the
sugar and adds four eggs to that he
mixes those in to create one cohesive
mixture and then strains that into
another bowl oil a pan with a rolled
paper towel and add some of the egg
mixture to it it might pop up a bit so
just pop any of the bubbles with your
chopsticks and push them all towards the
front as if you're rolling a carpet oil
it up one more time and add a bit more
eggs make sure to get underneath the
first roll so it kind of glues together
a bit you're gonna have to do this three
more times until it's one large roll at
this point just transfer to a plate and
that's it never seen an omelet this
color but it looks like and it's not
gonna have any flavor to it because
there is no ingredients other than an
egg on it visually it's a no for me this
looks sweet
it likes sparkles the roll is really
perfect look at that roll it doesn't
look like there's anything in it it's
just an egg over and over and over again
I even know what I'm tasting right now I
really like this
there's definitely something sweet about
it I don't think there's enough
happening for me to like it
it's a thumbs down I like this I'm
feeling this half of the food eating
experiences like aesthetics so I dig
this
I love Cool J starts by separating a
whopping nine egg whites from their
yolks he sprays a pan on nonstick spray
adds diced yellow and red peppers and
cooks those until tender you're gonna
want to break up your egg whites just a
little bit so they're not all stuck
together add some spinach to the pan
salt and pepper and let the spinach wilt
so it gets nice and tender add your egg
whites back to the pan and push them
around with your rubber spatula a little
bit to help them cook evenly season
again with salt and pepper and let them
cook up so they set all the way on the
bottom fold it in half into a half moon
shape transfer it on to a plate and
that's it turns out nine egg yolks is
how 50 rolls stays so ripped whoa egg
whites are we healthy or not a lot of
vegetables happening it's important to
get your vitamins I mean its eggs so how
bad could it be
mm-hmm pretty bad yeah it tastes way too
healthy like something my mom is forcing
me to eat the vegetables don't add
anything it just tastes like vegetables
and eggs and it's not one thing together
shame on you whoever invented this
recipe
I know all the Amish that we tried today
I'm definitely gonna go with number four
this one I like the texture of it was
cooked just right it really just had
flavor oh wait this is the chef Beaumont
Morimoto this look good for me one time
my favorite wine it was obviously the
first one with like the cheesy filling
just like savory and like salty enough I
really liked it oh the BAM do that
my favorite omelette today you're gonna
come for me in the comments is omelet
number one I think the eggs were cooked
nicely in that one they were the
fluffiest they were the lightest egg and
cheese think you got yourself a good
omelet
really I feel like Emeril is just like
bold BAM flavors in your face and there
wasn't anything like wild about that
interesting and BAM there you have it
Emeril Lagasse makes the best omelet
[Music]
which celebrity recipe you want us to
try next hit us up in the comments
[Music]